[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
feliz jueves vamos a hablar de argentina
porque hallar la moneda de ese país en
el mercado paralelo cayó a su nivel más
alto en la historia así es raúl pero de
hecho se registró una brecha del 95 por
ciento en comparación con el cambio
oficial en argentina se usa el dólar
oficial y el dólar blue del mercado
paralelo el oficial es el valor del
dólar que es elegida por parte del
gobierno mientras que el blue se
intercambia en plazas de dólares libres
de las restricciones oficiales pero
regularmente a un precio más alto el
dólar el dólar bruce cerró la jornada en
210 pesos argentino para la compra y 213
para la venta el dólar llamado dólar
brook es de escaso volumen de
operaciones pero funciona como un
indicador sensible a las expectativas
por ejemplo el blues se vendía a 165
pesos a principios de 2021 llegó a 200
pesos a principios de noviembre pasado y
cerró el 2021 en 208 pesos por dólar con
una pérdida de casi el 21 por ciento en
ese país raúl
fue del
59% en 2021 una de las más altas del
mundo escuchemos un poco cómo reacciona
los argentinos a este tipo de cambio
si va a seguir subiendo lamentablemente
son problemas acá en argentina no puede
solucionar el tema de la inflación y los
costos que tiene
estaría bueno qué
que se solucionará y no se ve inmediato
a subir de peso precios la inflación
misma
el volcán marcado
vamos a comprar y salimos al otro día
jorge de argentinos vamos a europa vamos
a la eurozona y su dato de la inflación
así es bueno eurostat que es la agencia
de la unión europea
confirmó que la inflación se disparó
allí en niveles récord en diciembre los
precios al consumidor en los 19 países
que comparten el euro subieron un 0,4
por ciento intermensual en diciembre o
sea comparado con el mes anterior aunque
contrastado con el dato de la misma
fecha del año pasado el salto fue del 5%
esta cifra es producto del aumento de
los precios de la energía y los cuellos
de botella en la cadena de suministros
en una zona económica que apenas está
buscando cómo recuperarse de los cierres
por la pandemia las tasas anuales más
bajas se registraron en malta portugal y
finlandia mientras que la más alta se
registraron en estonia lituania y
polonia
christine lagarde quien es directora del
banco central europeo aseguró a radio
france que espera que la inflación en la
zona euro se reduzca gradualmente a lo
largo de este año jorge porque hoy
podría ser un día decisivo en turquía
bueno muchos analistas están a la espera
de que hoy el presidente de ese país
pues tome medidas económicas tras el
colapso que causó bajar los tipos de
interés en momentos de alta inflación la
caída de la moneda y el aumento de los
precios mundiales de la energía llevaron
a los precios al consumidor a niveles
más altos desde el inicio del gobierno
del presidente de ahí perdonan mientras
los bancos centrales del mundo subieron
los tipos de interés turquía los ha
recortado en 500 puntos básicos desde
septiembre un ciclo un poco agresivo de
que el presidente apuesta para impulsar
el crecimiento y promover la fabricación
y las exportaciones unos 200 economistas
que fueron encuestados por bloomberg
esperan que el banco central mantenga el
tipo de referencia a una semana en el
14% la publicación agregó que turquía
tiene previsto inyectar 3 mil 800
millones de dólares a los bancos
estatales para garantizar de alguna
forma que sigan prestando a las empresas
después de que la caída récord de la
liga afectó sus reservas está ahora por
verse si oficializan esta decisión
e indicadores económicos bueno
arrancamos con hacia ahí las acciones
japonesas subían mientras en corea y
australia cayeron las acciones europeas
cayeron ya que los inversores cautelosos
se mantienen a la espera de que la
reserva federal de eeuu comience a subir
los tipos de interés este año jorge
gracias entonces por toda la información
de economía ya más adelante tenemos otro
bloque económico vamos a pasar ahora a
ver nuestro reportaje
[Música]